[Music]
what are joshua and ryan's top three
consumer regrets
my first one is that private jet we
bought
it is an arm and a leg i don't regret it
at all i'm happy without my arm and leg
[Laughter]
oh man uh no we we have some i mean
let's talk about regrets real quick in
this sense that
if i regretted something doesn't mean i
still regret it today
as soon as i learn the lesson
from the thing that i regret purchasing
regret bringing into my life yes
the lesson helps me let go of the regret
or helps you joke the regret
the guilt yes my shame is tamed that's
right that's all right so uh here are
three things that
i purchased and then regretted the first
one was i built a house when i was 22.
and
i didn't know any better yeah and i
wasn't really intentional with it so
it probably wasn't in the location where
i would have built a house it was just i
was sort of just going with the motions
going with the flow this is what you are
supposed to do and when we start making
decisions based on this is what i'm
supposed to do it tends to lead to
regret because it leads to a lot of
unintentional purchases which lead to
regress so i built this house it was a
you know this uh three bedroom two and a
half car garage two living rooms full
basement it was too much space for me
and my former spouse
and we
felt compelled then to fill it with
stuff as well which led to other
consumer regrets as we started buying
all these things we didn't need but we
felt the house was incomplete and if the
house was incomplete then we as human
beings must be incomplete yeah and
so it was kind of a cookie cutter house
suburban house i wouldn't have ever
purchased the house that's a weird thing
and just building it was like well this
is what i'm supposed to do right oh plus
i'm getting a good deal on it i'd be
stupid not to the interest rates are low
the down payment is zero dollars right
now
you know that was
2003 or whatever it was
and so
i
certainly regretted that i would have
done a lot of things differently had i
been intentional so intentional
purchases would have led me to making
radically different decisions with
building or purchasing a house it's not
that building a house or purchasing
house was wrong i would have made
different decisions along the way yeah i
got two more for you here ryan i bought
a land rover discovery in 2004
and then very quickly changed uh so we
managed a bunch of retail stores i
changed stores and i had to start
driving it was like hundred miles a day
yeah and i'm driving this giant gas
guzzler right and i'm spending it's like
two or three times the money that i was
on gas
within a month of buying the thing right
and i was like oh i wasn't intentional
with this purchase and so i didn't think
about the thing we were talking about
earlier the things have to be paid for
twice you buy the car
that's the price up front but the gas
is the second price and the oil changes
and the maintenance of a land rover has
all the maintenance charges right isn't
there a company in la that literally
their whole business is predicated on
you bring your brand new land rover to
them and they just automatically fix
everything they know that it already it
has a problem with there is that joke
that they're known for leaking on the
lot right yeah and i don't know if they
still do but they did back then and so
there was a ton of mains eventually i
sold it relatively quickly and a huge
loss which led to more regret but there
were lessons there i learned that lesson
i've let go of the regatta still regret
it at this point
in fact i was talking to podcast sean
about this this morning and he seemed to
misunderstand the what we were trying to
accomplish here because i asked him what
the lessons from the regrets he's like
well i don't have any regrets and i'm
like yeah but tell me about the lessons
you've learned because as soon as you've
learned the lesson
you start to
that regret just dissipates on its own
and the regret in that sense becomes
beneficial
it becomes
corrosive
when we don't learn the lesson right and
so we hold on to the regret it eats at
us and it provides more anxiety and
stress in our lives here's one more
regret it's not a specific one but i can
give you some specifics around it
going into any debt except except
mortgage debt
and yeah
so
i think about the 14 credit cards i had
back in the day so i was one of those
one in 10 americans who have 10 or more
active credit cards yeah i had 14. i had
a banana republic i had a macy's card i
had diners club i had sears i had an
elder biermann's club which is a
department store in dayton which
here's the irony i was banned from that
store if you if you read a lot of people
use things
i was actually arrested in that store oh
my goodness i'm not going to go through
all the details of that right now but i
still had a credit card so i could shop
there but i have to sneak in i guess
right now
i signed up for those credit cards why
because you get 10 off today on that 70
shirt and so i save seven dollars today
for 70 700
dollars worth of regret in the future i
did that was banana republic i did with
macy's i did it with american express
and mastercard and visa right
and
oh
man
i just remember how
overwhelmed i was
and how
this is a true story i've never told
before
so i have all this credit card debt
100 000 worth of credit card debt mm-hmm
i've gotten driving around that land
rover mm-hmm
driving up uh
i'm driving 275 to i-71 in ohio
and i there's that i'm driving up i-71
on my way toward columbus
there's a tallest bridge in ohio
and there
there was a day where i was
planning on driving the car off the
bridge
because this
was the only way out it felt like i was
so stifled by debt
that i felt like ending it all easiest
way out was
not just the easiest way you're right
but it felt to me at the time it was
wrong but it felt to me at the time like
it was the only way out yeah that's what
debt does to us that's how corrosive
debt
is
i got four more bonus non-consumer
regrets but i'd love to hear from yours
uh first ryan sure i can get into those
um i'll tell you what though that bridge
you're talking about they actually had
to put
walls up because
several people
did what you did a friend of ours you
were thinking about doing jumped off of
it yeah yeah
yeah it's man what a shame and it was
because it was because of debt
yes it was yeah i mean that's what it
came down to yeah man
what a pernicious thing
so we're talking about uh consumer
regrets i talked about one in the
minimal
episode about
um getting a new car every two years
and essentially like the the last brand
new car i bought that was the last brand
new car i bought it was a bugatti
yeah
it was uh like a toyota solaire or
something and it had i had a truck that
was real it was a really awesome truck
and i was about three years away from
paying it off
but it needed new tires it needed new
brakes it needed a lot of maintenance
and i get the
quote on the maintenance and it was um
if it wasn't five hundred dollars it was
like fifteen hundred dollars i just
remember being a lot
and i'm like
huh
my car payment's only 200 bucks a month
300 bucks a month
maybe i could just take the equity from
this
get get a new car and just keep that
payment going
and uh
yeah i can avoid spending two thousand
dollars right now or whatever it was
and i i get in that i go to the lot i
get in the toyota i'm driving it around
and you know the new car smell like
that's
that alone like makes you think about
buying a new car
it was nice and shiny and clean
but then
i realized it had bluetooth
and that is what that's what sold it for
me i was like ah
bluetooth
like this is amazing like this this
tells you how long ago like that you
know we were live but also i i was uh
connected with my blackberry
[Laughter]
so it strikes me that
we justify i can pay 500 a month for
bluetooth because that's essentially
what you're talking about bluetooth
accessory yeah which really i could have
just
i could have just bought a radio which
and i learned that lesson because that
toyota corolla remember the radio like
eventually went out yeah i had a buddy
who worked at a sound uh sound place in
missoula montana and um gave me a really
good deal like a nice little radio and
some speakers and it had bluetooth and i
could have just done that with my truck
rather than like trading in it so i had
to learn
learned that lesson the hard way i
remember when you got the corolla
and
you we you didn't have bluetooth
obviously but we had you see in our
first documentary the cassette tape you
hooked into the ipod yes and isn't it
better to use that than to pay 500 a
month for bluetooth oh my goodness a
hundred percent better 100 better what
else you got
uh you know i remember
when i when we first started down the
the the minimalism road
i went i needed a shaver
so i went to you know whatever
department store
to get a shaver
and there's all these options paradox of
choice right um
man i don't know how do i know which
one's which
amazon wasn't really anything so it's
not like i could really look at reviews
um
nor did i feel like i needed to go look
at reviews for you know something to
shave my my scruff
so i'm like well
i'm a minimalist um i'm doing this
because you know i want to regain
control of my time and the way i can
regain control of my time is by
regaining control of my finances so i'm
gonna get like the cheapest
the cheapest shaver that i can get
it lasted about uh i think the warranty
on it was 30 days it lasted about 30 and
a half days
[Laughter]
and i was i was so mad because it yeah
it was just a piece of junk
and uh yeah the regret there was not
a doing a little bit of research
beforehand and b
um i could have just freaking
yeah i could have just spent a little
bit more a little bit more money and got
the better quality item yeah and instead
of like trying to and almost in a way i
kind of look back at like me being
self-righteous in that situation i'm a
minimalist i'm gonna spend as little
money as possible
so you know that's another lesson i
learned like just because you're a
minimalist doesn't mean you have to be
cheap
yes i think that's important because
there are these extra costs the cost of
replacing the thing
when we
buy the cheap thing we and so that's
another way you weren't actually being
intentional because you were looking at
one dimension of three dimensions right
you were looking at merely the price
point well the best price point is not
to buy it at all because then you pay
zero dollars but that also doesn't get
you what you want yeah so
not buying the thing didn't get you what
you want
buying the cheapest version of the thing
didn't get you what you want yeah both
of those things would lead to regret but
also buying the five thousand dollar
gold-plated shaver would lead to regret
as well yeah and for you the best thing
was somewhere in between much closer to
the to the zero dollar item
but something that is going to last a
while in fact
that's what intentional purchasing does
it allows us to buy the thing so we have
to so we can stop worrying about
the thing replacing the thing buying
another thing getting a better version
of the thing we get the thing that is
enough so we can move on and stop
worrying about the purchase at all yeah
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com slash the minimalists
or click the link in the description
your support keeps our podcast and
youtube channel 100 percent
free